for the thrill of chasing a high score
for all the great heroes who captured
our imaginations and the villains we
like more than the heroes waiting 20
years for it and finally getting a good
pac-man game for the games that have no
end that we still try to finish and the
self-imposed challenges when the game
hasn't hardened and when it still isn't
hard enough we face the best online for
the in-your-face scares and all the
times we're afraid to Trek into the
darkness all those grueling hours spent
getting rare items and all the grueling
hours finding obscure games for the
countless times we save the princess
only to find she was in another castle
for the power of the triforce which will
never really understand for the fun of
meeting our friends with cheap movies
but then agreeing to go two out of three
for all the secret moves we show off for
the sound of those clicking buttons and
for the satisfaction we get one who
finally realized the solution which is
right in front of our faces the whole
time for the Konami code for late nights
with old friends and the really late
nights with new friends for the e3 press
conferences for just a small glimpse of
the future for the cool gadgets that are
still awesome they don't work right for
the Great's and the years they dedicated
to our entertainment for the baddest and
for the characters who define
generations for the old tech and the new
and for all the great things that have
never fit one video
this is why we love video games game
over